[Music]
hey you guys it's us
once again yeah talking about another
move what are you smirking at talking
about a movie i didn't see
well you were sitting there i just don't
think you were paying attention i forgot
which one this was which one was this
it was the one with the girl the mom and
the uh the crazy mom and the girl in the
wheelchair
yeah okay yeah i wasn't really paying
attention yeah i know it didn't pull me
in
and i got distracted yeah you were it
didn't look like a bad movie though
it was actually really good i quite
liked it this uh this movie is called
run and it's on
hulu at the moment i think that this
movie was actually supposed to
open in theaters last may uh in time for
mother's day which if you've seen the
movie is actually very funny
because the movie and the the mother in
this is
is nuts um but obviously the whole
pandemic thing happened and uh hulu
eventually ended up buying it and i
think they premiered it like
well it's only like 10 days ago or
something like that it hasn't been on
there that long because i've seen like a
lot of other reviews of it
so basically this is it's kind
it's hard to talk about without spoiling
it but i will say that
even from watching the trailer you can
probably guess
like what's gonna happen
kinda like not exactly what's gonna
happen but you can kind of guess what
the angle is
so you know if you don't want to know
anything about it then
you know maybe don't listen to me
talking about it but i'm not going to
like ruin it but i am probably going to
talk about it a little bit
but so basically so sarah paulson is in
this man she's in everything these days
she's in ratchet she's in which is
another thing that i need to
get onto and watch but i haven't had
time to so far
and she's a mom and at the very
beginning um
she gives birth to a drastically
premature baby
and you know implication being so then
they jump ahead like 17 years when the
daughter is a teenager
and the daughter chloe has like all
kinds of
medical difficulties she said you know
she has paralysis she has diabetes she
has all these butt
she's still like really capable she's
really intelligent she seems to be like
um getting on with her
life now her mom is homeschooling her
and they have like a really strange
codependent relationship not like
anything horrifying at first
but as it goes on it gets kind of like
weirder and weirder
and long story short um one particular
thing like chloe has applied to a bunch
of colleges and is like
you know avidly waiting for her
acceptance letters
and um she doesn't seem to be getting
any and then she starts getting
suspicious that maybe her mom
is like doing something that maybe she
shouldn't be doing like i think she
first gets suspicious
um for with some new medication that
she's given
and um then she starts kind of like
trying to investigate because the the
thing about the relationship between
these two i mean there's a couple other
people in the movie but it's mostly just
these two it's sarah paulson playing the
mom and uh
a girl named kira allen as the daughter
i think that kyra allen i think this
might be her first role or her first
major role
and i thought it was cool that she is
actually disabled and she is actually in
a wheelchair so they actually got
somebody that was really
instead of just like having somebody
fake it which i thought was kind of nice
because there are a few scenes in this
where she has to do like some
physical things like to escape and stuff
like that so i thought it made it like a
lot more
harrowing you know what i mean because
you knew that she couldn't really walk
so um so she starts to suspect that
something is like
uh not so cool with her mom and
like i said i don't want to spoil it
outright
but as i said if you watch the trailer
you will probably not be surprised to
know that this
is one of your uh cases of munchausen
syndrome by proxy that's all i'm going
to say
and so pretty much this it reminds me a
little bit of
it had plot elements of like misery
kind of had bits that reminded me of
that uh rear window that kind of stuff
so it's like it's basically it's just a
very simple
thriller story um there's a couple
things in there that maybe aren't
super super believable especially um
the fact that the mom is able to keep
her daughter so much like from going
online at least like without her like
supervising it
um but honestly like any thriller you
watch is gonna have like unbelievable
[ __ ] in it because that's just like how
they roll
so i thrilling if it
right because it's like then it would be
super boring because everybody would be
just like yeah
yeah yeah it's not gonna happen pizza
man is coming
right that's like exactly so you do have
to but i didn't think there was anything
in here that like strained cajuli
credulity too much and um
the way that it shakes out like i said
i'm not gonna spoil it but
i do remember um a couple of cases
like real life true crime cases that
were similar to what happened in this
one
so it's not like totally banana pants
like crazy out there
um but yeah i thought this was like a
really good like
simple thriller type movie nothing fancy
nothing i mean the editing was very good
the acting was very good
um this is only this guy this director
is named anish
uh shiganti and i think this is only his
second movie he also made one called
searching which i haven't seen but i've
heard is really really good
so i will probably be watching it um on
that like of the recommendation of that
but uh yeah so this is on hulu if you
like thrillers then
check it out because it's actually
pretty good so ken was the one that uh
initially because he he said i didn't he
didn't know if
i had seen the recommendation i did but
i didn't remember that it was either
recommend i knew that somebody did or
i think tila might have recommended it
as well okay and um
so and i kept seeing it come up like
because i've subscribed to like a lot of
um you know horror and thriller
review channels so i kept seeing it come
up and i was like oh well i have hulu so
i should pretty
probably watch that and like give my
input
so you know but uh what i'm just trying
to think of i wonder what [ __ ] cigar
would think of this movie
you wonder what cigar would think of
this with maybe he'd be like
i don't like the movie i don't like
killing people in movies
[Laughter]
well and also i should add that it might
make him jealous in this movie because
uh the act the actress the young actress
that's in this movie who is actually
disabled and she actually does like
crawl around and [ __ ] like that which
steven seagal is perfectly able and
can't even like get up and walk down
some stairs
so see i don't believe that just saying
i don't believe that
i don't believe that i don't believe in
abusing the handicap
they need to stay at home depressed
then they can always hire a stunt double
make that girl jump out of a wheelchair
like that
that's inhumane and she did like other
[ __ ] too like climbing out of windows
and
falling down stairs and [ __ ] like that i
don't believe in that you don't believe
in that
no i don't believe in that
now we need because you haven't done btk
for a while now we need a steven seagal
bobble head so you can still make him
like easier to channel
somebody's got to make a scene
i got a very special psychic ability i
can channel the souls of the living
[Laughter]
there's another t-shirt right there
that's like that's like some [ __ ] that
the thing can do from [ __ ]
john carpenter is the thing yeah
channeling the souls i don't know just
just sounds like something that the
thing would do yeah okay that's fair
enough yeah anybody can channel the
souls of the dead
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
why don't you do something hard yeah but
yes
stealing the souls of a living person
somebody tell me that somebody's made a
stephen cigal bobblehead or at least a
vinyl like a pop figure
somebody must have they've made [ __ ]
they're steven seagal action figures
an action figure yeah fully possibly
look good it just sits
no i actually was funny it's like the
action figure that i saw it was steven
seagal in top physical condition
well yeah no he's like although it would
be it would be funnier if they had like
nowadays
they got like an action figure that and
he was just like sitting on a couch
though
in his [ __ ] in his vegas phase like
elvis is in vegas
yeah oh my god yeah vegas the vegas
phase
that's that's the term that i use when
something is at the end
[Laughter]
like the united states is now in its
vegas phase if you ask me it's just you
know
well honestly i think that there's one
more phase beyond that which would be
your
branson missouri phase
branson is kind of like the poor man's
law oh it is
okay it's like where all the old people
go to gamble and like
eat at buffets and [ __ ] yeah that must
have been where [ __ ] bubba hotep was
filmed
oh we're no i'm that was in texas
somewhere yeah well because like i said
joe or landsdale uh wrote the story and
he's from texas and most of his stories
are
set there so i'm pretty sure that was
texas yeah
but uh yeah so somebody asked what does
seagal think of btk
[Laughter]
[ __ ] now he's like [ __ ] and what does
btk think of seagal
they would hate you know what they would
[ __ ] hate each other they probably
wouldn't they would hate each other and
they would [ __ ] talk [ __ ] about each
other yeah you know
because they're [ __ ] yeah again you
know [ __ ] be you say
cigar say running around pretending like
he's a good citizen and
like he's a hero and but we know that we
know that he's a violent man
beating people's asses and and and
taking advantage of women
it's it's bad for the community that's
what btk would say
yeah i could see that yeah i could see
that he needs
he needs to get right with god and do
some time in the church and
he's he he's he's a bad man he's it's
not acceptable
and he doesn't never mow his lawn
[Laughter]
i measured
and then [ __ ] come in and goes yeah
that loser
only way you can get laid is if she's
dead oh
damn that got dark
see me on the other hand i have all
these beautiful assistants
from all over eastern europe yeah
phil i have a little swim
[Laughter]
and then i drink it it's the punati pool
[Laughter]
shows up
oh my god somebody somebody writes
steven seagal an email and tell him that
he needs to write a song called punani
pool
i might i might even paint
[Music]
[Laughter]
every live stream we do should end with
scotland
with us shouting out steven seagal one
of these days he will be
become aware of our [ __ ] i hear the
[ __ ] doorbell ring
and [ __ ] i look out through the hand
and i see that [ __ ] hairline
and that [ __ ] mustache oh
[Laughter]
i've been watching your live streams i
need one of his eyebrows up
[Laughter]
i know this one's kind of short today
but we just got some rolls out of the
oven so we got to go
eat some of those before they get cold
yeah
uh but yeah so we will be back tomorrow
i've already picked out
a uh movie to watch i'm not gonna tell
you what it is it'll be a surprise
i already picked out a movie to watch
tonight that i can review tomorrow
but yeah like i said if you like
thrillers particularly ones that are
like small
cast very simple nothing new or anything
like that but
it's just a really well executed like
kind of simple thriller so if you dig
that kind of thing and you have hulu
then uh check it out by all means and uh
as always thanks for stopping by
thanks thank you btk and steven seagal
for your guest appearances
those are always much appreciated yeah
[Laughter]
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow